This lesson covers traffic engineering. Traffic
engineering is the process of reconfiguring the
network in response to changing traffic loads
to achieve some operational goal. A network
operator might want to reconfigure the network in response to changing loads to,
for example, maintain traffic ratios in a
peering relationship or to relieve congestion on
certain links in the network or to balance
load more evenly across the available links in
the network. In this lesson we will explore
different ways of performing traffic engineering. We will
start by looking at conventional approaches to traffic
engineering and we'll explore how software-defined networking is
used to make the process of traffic engineering
easier in both data center networks and transit networks.
IP networks must be managed. Now, in
some sense, IP networks manage themselves. There
are several examples of protocols on the
internet that in some sense manage themselves. TCP
senders send less traffic during congestion and
routing protocols will adapt to topology changes.
The problem is that even though these
protocols are designed to adapt to various changes,
the network may not run efficiently. There
may be congested links when idle paths exist
or there might be a high-delay path that
some traffic is taking when a low-delay path,
in fact, exists. So key question that
traffic engineering tries to address is how routing
should adapt to traffic. In particular, traffic engineering
attempts to avoid congested links and satisfy certain
application requirements such as delay. These are,
in some sense, the essential questions that traffic
engineering attempts to answer. In the rest of this lesson we will look at how
network operators can tune a routing protocol
configuration to affect how network traffic traverses the
links in the network. And in particular
we will look at both intradomain traffic engineering,
that is how to reconfigure the protocols
within a single autonomous system to adjust traffic
flows, as well as interdomain traffic engineering, or
how to adjust how traffic flows between autonomous
system. We will also look at multi-path routing and how it is used to achieve
various traffic engineering goals. Let's start by looking
how network operators can tune static link weights
in a routing protocol like OSPF or ISIS,
to affect how traffic flows through the network.